[Música]
el presidente volodimir se les dijo que
el ataque contra un hospital materno
infantil en mariupol es prueba del
genocidio de ucranianos de la invasión
rusa al menos 17 heridos dejó el
bombardeo en medio de la apertura de
corredores humanitarios
precisamente quien reportó que 35 mil
ucranianos fueron evacuados a través de
corredores humanitarios de tres ciudades
este miércoles aunque bombardeos y
obstaculizaciones de las fuerzas de
kremlin han dificultado la uis
y los efectos de la guerra empiezan a
verse en los precios de los alimentos
alrededor del mundo especialmente en los
países más vulnerables solo rusia y
ucrania exportan casi el 30% de trigo a
nivel mundial por lo que se está
interrumpiendo su flujo habitual
[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz empezamos hablando de
la devastación por la guerra en ucrania
fue bombardeado un hospital
materno-infantil en la ciudad de
mariupol durante las horas del alto el
fuego para permitir la huida de miles de
civiles atrapados en la ciudad el
presidente voló de excelencia y denunció
que la ofensiva fue prueba del genocidio
contra los ucranianos por parte de los
rusos el ataque ocurrió aún cuando
mariupol fue uno de los seis lugares
acordados con rusia para facilitar la
evacuación de ciudadanos sin embargo la
urbe continúa resistiendo al avance de
las tropas del kremlin que ya controlan
gran parte del sur del país actualmente
se encuentra muy cerca de mikolajki el
último punto clave antes de poder llegar
a odessa que es el principal puerto
industrial de ucrania escuchamos a
selenski
aga boom van a el ataque aéreo en el
hospital de maternidad es la prueba
final la prueba de que está ocurriendo
el genocidio de los ucranianos ucrania
y europa europeos no pueden decir que no
vieron lo que pasó con los ucranianos
lo que pasó en mariupol con la gente de
mariupol y
además se les informó que alrededor de
35.000 ucranianos fueron evacuados a
través de corredores humanitarios de
tres ciudades este miércoles y agregó
que las autoridades planeaban abrir
otras seis rutas de escape denunció que
los esfuerzos de rescate se
concentrarían en mariupol e hice un que
han sido fuertemente bombardeadas en
lucha al noroeste de kiev las
autoridades reportaron que los militares
rusos habían impedido el paso de unos 50
autobuses en suma cerca de la frontera
con rusia sólo han podido escapar unos
5.000 civiles mientras que eni sium
cerca de jarkko se retrasó la huida
debido a los bombardeos los países
europeos son los que están acogiendo a
los migrantes
con el estallido de la guerra en ucrania
cientos de miles de personas han huido
de su país buscando un nuevo hogar en
alguna de las naciones vecinas según la
onu hasta el momento polonia es la que
más ucranianos ha recibido con más de 12
millones de personas refugiadas
conway
tuve mucho miedo durante todo el camino
porque leí que muchas personas
recibieron disparos cuando intentaban
salir de la ciudad y ser ni big es una
de las ciudades donde hay disparos
masivos fue realmente aterrador
[Música]
en segundo lugar hungría ha dado la
bienvenida a más de 200.000 personas la
mayoría niños y mujeres que ahora
esperan encontrar trabajo para poder
salir adelante en un país extranjero
cuando una estábamos en casa sabíamos de
los puestos de trabajo en hungría y que
conseguiríamos trabajo aquí también
existía la posibilidad de ir con un
familiar a alemania pero hungría está
más cerca
también eslovaquia y rumanía han
recibido a una gran cantidad de
ucranianos más de 99.000 y 85.000
respectivamente en ciudades como
superaba a los hoteles se han convertido
en refugios para migrantes con decenas
de voluntarios dispuestos a ayudar
hasta ahora desde que la guerra empezó
hemos acogido a unas 3.000 personas aquí
en las habitaciones en el gran salón de
baile en esta sala y también en mi
despacho
office en medio de la crisis de
refugiados la onu advierte que el éxodo
será aún mayor y mientras las naciones
vecinas además de dar refugio a los
desplazados mandan mensajes y pedidos de
paz el secretario de estado de estados
anthony blinken recibió en washington a
su homóloga británica listos y se
pronunciaron sobre los pedidos de
selenski de una zona de exclusión aérea
atrás dijo que establecer la conduciría
a una confrontación directa entre la
otan y rusia y blinken repitió que
entregar aviones de combate por la cosa
kiev está descartado
dice la decisión sobre si transferir
algún equipo a nuestros amigos en
ucrania es en última instancia una que
cada gobierno decidirá por sí mismo y
tiene que tomar
andrés con su sitio web estamos en una
estrecha consulta con aliados y socios
sobre la asistencia de seguridad en
curso a ucrania los yaks a aysén porque
de hecho creo que lo que estamos viendo
porque que la propuesta de polonia
muestra que hay algunas complejidades
que presenta el tema cuando se trata de
brindar asistencia de seguridad es
crisis rusia y ucrania son importantes
exportadores de grano y la guerra está
impidiendo el flujo habitual por lo que
los precios de alimentos clave están
aumentando y afectando especialmente a
países vulnerables una repercusión que
llega hasta los combustibles registrando
máximos históricos en el precio
los efectos de la guerra se hacen notar
esto es nacido en irak
los ciudadanos iraquíes deben recibir
una parte del petróleo lo exigimos desde
ahora y hasta que se cumplan nuestras
demandas el alza en los precios de los
combustibles preocupa en todo el mundo y
en bagdad la capital iraquí también el
aumento de los precios de los alimentos
donde el costo del aceite casi se
cuatriplicó
como pueden creer que tengo que pagar 15
dólares por una lata de aceite como lo
voy a hacer también hay gastos en la
casa en la escuela cómo vamos a vivir la
vida
ucrania prohibió la exportación de trigo
avena y otros alimentos básicos y a
2.400 kilómetros está teniendo impacto
en el mayor importador de trigo del
mundo egipto depende del grano ucraniano
aunque el gobierno asegura tener
reservas para todo 2022 al otro lado del
mediterráneo en túnez la preocupación es
mayor y caixa jet presidente tunecino
golpear mandó una advertencia en plena
escasez
duna aguarda quiero que sea una guerra
implacable contra los especuladores
criminales pero la crisis también llega
hasta los países occidentales en
alemania los precios del diésel están en
niveles récord mientras hay una escasez
de entre 60 y 80 mil conductores
pues la guerra de ucrania ha provocado
que los precios del diésel se disparen
de manera exorbitante actualmente
tenemos entre 50 y 60 centavos por litro
de costos adicionales en este segmento
lamentablemente tenemos que trasladar
este aumento de costos a nuestros
clientes
los impactos en las exportaciones clave
desde ucrania y rusia también afectan al
transporte en un aumento del precio que
acabará afectando a todos los productos
transportados mientras los países de la
unión europea buscan soluciones para
depender menos del gas ruso la
explotación de uno de los más grandes
yacimientos de europa ubicado en países
bajos debería suspenderse este año esto
debido a que las perforaciones están
provocando repetidos terremotos pero con
las amenazas sobre el suministro de gas
la producción podría retomarse
en este campo tranquilo no se esperaría
un terremoto aún así el último golpeó
hace sólo unos días regla terminó por
acostumbrarse y es que en 30 años se
sintieron más de 1500 sismos
durante uno de esos terremotos esta
puerta ya no quería abrirse y yo quería
salir porque escuchaba que las paredes
se fisura van tan fuerte que tenía la
impresión de que teníamos que salir que
la casa estaba derrumbándose
desde el inicio de la guerra reina está
aún más inquieta a unos tres kilómetros
de aquí se encuentra el yacimiento de
groninga el más grande de europa su
explotación debía pararse este año
porque justamente es ésta la causante de
los terremotos pero con las amenazas
rusas sobre el suministro de gas hacia
europa podría el contrario aumentar su
producción una buena opción según
especialistas desde un punto de vista
estrictamente técnico
es una forma de compromiso que la
sociedad neerlandesa debe hacer
aumentamos la producción en groninga
para depender menos de los rusos pero
con el riesgo de generar más terremotos
es
una perspectiva difícil de entender para
los habitantes de la región que temen
las consecuencias a futuro
si nos cortan el gas ruso esto va a
generar un problema más grande más gas
será sacado en groningen y seremos
nosotros quienes estaremos bajo carpas
este habitante también está preocupado
porque tuvo que dejar su casa
considerada demasiado peligrosa a pesar
de todo quiere ser solidario
tenemos que pensar también en nuestros
vecinos europeos
quién soy para decir que no explotar
hemos gas guau guau informer cuando a
dos horas en vuelo de aquí hay gente que
muere porque rusia bombardea su país
están todavía 450 mil millones de metros
cúbicos de gas justo bajo mis pies a
pesar de la inquietud de los habitantes
de la región un reciente estudio
demostró que dos tercios de la población
está de acuerdo con aumentar la
explotación y así depender menos del gas
ruso
hasta aquí esta informativa en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]